if you're visiting LA and you want to go
to the beach specifically and I'm sure
I'm going to get hate for this people
who live in Malibu are going to be like
no but this beach is already kind of
ruined and it's viral whatever it's like
very much so photographed and whatever
El Mador is an amazing beach in Malibu
it's beautiful there's like awesome
stairs that bring you down to the water
and it's gorgeous there's like rocks
everywhere it almost feels like you're
in Capri it's it's it's an amazing place
um but people who live in Malibu get
very protected of it and they're like
stop telling everyone about our beach
but if you're there when it's warm or
when it's not it's always warm who are
we kidding